[Música]
buenos días
yo no soy tan brillante como los días
anteriores ese chico [ __ ]
les van a permitirme que al hablar de sí
ni su religión tenga que restringir me
dado en el tema de la restricción del
tiempo
a la relación entre ciencia y religión
católica porque si no tendría que
emplear mucho más tiempo iban a
permitirme también que comience con una
lectura voy a leer un texto de un
divulgador muy conocido en el mundo
occidental
woods índice
pues simple coincidencia que la ciencia
moderna se desarrollase en un medio
ampliamente católico o había algo en el
catolicismo que favoreció el éxito de la
ciencia
el mero hecho de formular la pregunta
supone una transgresión de la opinión
mayoritaria sin embargo cada vez son más
los académicos que se plantean la
cuestión y llegan a veces a conclusiones
sorprendentes el asunto no es baladí la
supuesta hostilidad de la iglesia
católica hacia la ciencia es quizás uno
de los mayores lastres de una cultura
popular
a la versión unilateral sobre galileo en
la mayoría de la gente conoce debemos en
buena parte la generalización de las
creencias según las cuales la iglesia ha
impedido el avance de la investigación
científica
aunque el incidente de galileo hubiera
sido tan negativo como la gente supone
ya un henry cardenal newman convertido
del anglicanismo en el siglo 19 encontró
revelador que éste fuera casi el único
ejemplo que la gente es capaz de citar
hasta aquí la cita de woods
yo estoy de acuerdo con wood es en esto
de que formular la pregunta ya supone
una transgresión de la opinión
mayoritaria nosotros conocemos eso lo
sabemos de memoria sin entrar en
exageraciones sin caer en aquellas
creencias que dicen que a galileo lo
quemaron lo torturaron el setter no no
sin llegar allá hay esa opinión
mayoritaria a pesar de que las pruebas
van en otro sentido a mí me llama la
atención profundamente que siempre se
hable de galileo
un señor que vivió en el siglo 17 16 17
en otras palabras han pasado ya varios
siglos y no oigo yo jamás cuando se
habla de oposición a la ciencia y se
mencione a mijail baby love
nadie recuerda eso en mis clases de la
universidad preguntaba y ni siquiera los
biólogos recordaban quién era baby love
y que recuerden quién era
para ver florence que peor todavía
porque algún botánico se acuerda de baby
love pero de flores que nadie porque es
que se acuerdan de un señor del siglo 16
17 y no de dos del siglo 20 misterio
insondable
también me llama la atención por ejemplo
que cuando se enseña el tema de la
revolución copernicana no se diga que
copérnico era un canónigo de la iglesia
católica era un eclesiástico o cuando se
pone en los libros la famosa teoría del
big bang' no se menciona que el creador
de esta idea a la que él llamó el átomo
primordial sea un sacerdote católico
jordi metro que llama la atención que se
recalque los de galileo no voy a
discutir el tema les doy la razón a
todos que están en contra de la iglesia
por galileo y allí me lleve o no me voy
a discutir eso pero digo porque no se
habla también del otro y como me muevo
un poco en el campo de la historia tengo
que decirles a ustedes que si uno revisa
la historia desde cuando la iglesia
católica comienza a influir en la
cultura más o menos siglo sexto después
de cristo hay antecedentes lógicamente
pero estos esto es un proceso muy muy
muy lento y hay
deseo de cambiar
en qué consiste la ciencia yo no soy
científico de saben yo soy tonto de
sociales
por consiguiente no puedo definir de
manera perfecta lo que es la ciencia
pero lo que enseña en el colegio perdón
lo que aprendí en el colegio es que la
ciencia se basa en la observación en la
experimentación en un método por eso
suele decirse que la ciencia aparece en
grecia los griegos inventan el método la
palabra método es griega está apodos a
través de un camino bien
observación experimentación
hay un libro que para mí es realmente un
atentado a la cultura un crimen
intelectual que se llama ideas
este libro está lleno de falsedades
históricas
y uno se pone a contar los errores
históricos y yo solamente he contado más
de 1000
y vamos a hacer
acabo de leer otro libro de un político
en que se dice que la experimentación
comenzó con cristóbal colón'
cuando quiso realmente probar que la
tierra es redonda los demás decían que
es plana y en el único que decía que era
redonda mentira podrida
toda la edad media' sabía que la tierra
es redonda la edad media no había
discusión al respecto pero no sólo eso
volvamos a la experimentación el primero
en experimentar no es colón tampoco es
leonardo hay anteriores por ejemplo
escuela de chartres allá en el año 1000
mil y pico y a los maestros les dicen a
los estudiantes que si quieren conocer
la naturaleza que deben hacer observar
investigar experimentar no deben basarse
ni en la autoridad
en la religión para observar la
naturaleza para entenderla ni en la
autoridad de aristóteles era tal vez el
peor lastre que había en esa época del
progreso de la ciencia y en el siglo 19
hago un paréntesis pierdo a mi escribió
un libro perdón me equivoqué a
principios del siglo 20 porque era por
1919 por ahí más o menos perduran
publicó un libro demostrando todos los
aportes minimales a la ciencia el
segundo tomo de ese libro tardó 60 años
en publicarse porque la gente no quería
los que tenían el poder sobre la
comunicación no querían que se publique
por lo que acabamos de decir el astro de
la cultura popular y cuando decimos
popular no queremos decir simplemente
del pueblo ignorante y letrado
también hay personas venidas y escribir
las que tienen que ser lastre de cultura
popular que seguiremos ese paréntesis y
sigamos ya en la escuela de chartres se
habla de investigar de observar si
pasamos a otras universidades medievales
parís oxford etcétera nos encontramos
con personajes que hacían investigación
que hacían experimentación con los
límites propios de la técnica de la
época no se olviden que
los monjes medievales los frailes
minerales los laicos medievales no
tenían todavía el microscopio o el
telescopio aunque según las últimas
investigaciones quienes inventan el
lente para poder leer mejor son los
monjes gente no es invento oriental como
se decía hasta hace poco también por
razones ideológicas
no tenían medios especializados pero
hacían lo posible por ejemplo mucho
antes de galileo puridad y ahí su
experimento sobre la caída de los
cuerpos
existen a pesar de las destrucciones
masivas de los documentos medievales
existen manuscritos en que se ve los
esquemas
estos monjes investigadores
experimentadores
votar hacer caer a un peso
[Música]
en el aire en el agua en aceite hacer
caer a un peso en un tubo o hacer caer a
un pez un tubo con agua para hacer caer
un peso en un embudo con agua ver la
diferencia de la caída hay experimentos
medievales sobre la luz no solamente con
el ojo simple no tenían todavía
telescopio por ejemplo llamaba la
atención porque se forme el arco iris
ya no se acepta la idea verdad
tradicional bíblica que es una señal de
la paz de enviada por dios eso está bien
para el asunto religioso
es un símbolo es un signo no pero hay
que probar científicamente usamos la
palabra moderna como se forme el arco
iris hay toda una investigación sobre la
luz
como pues observaban como pasa la luz a
través de una gota de agua más tarde
fabricaron pequeñas esferas de vidrio
con agua adentro el vidrio viene de
mucho antes pero comienzan a ser estas
de experimentaciones
y se da un paso más que comienza a decir
no basta que esto resulte una vez que
necesita una constante se necesita una
permanencia en los resultados el método
acaba de mencionar rápidamente oscuridad
podría hablar de muchos otros nombres
pero no les quiero a ustedes agotar con
eso también habla de la inercia pero no
usa la palabra inercia usa la palabra
latina ímpetus no llegará a la claridad
de newton pero en cambio si comienza a
reflexionar que el movimiento no se debe
a una serie de aspectos como decía
aristóteles porque un objeto se mantiene
en el aire aristóteles decía porque el
aire lo sostiene
unidad dice no señor hay una fuerza que
impulsa a ese objeto ímpetus etcétera
aquí podríamos nosotros hablar de muchos
otros aspectos de la
15 a medieval pero hay más como digo yo
quiero recalcar la mentalidad
las ideas claras hay que distinguir lo
que nosotros podemos saber interpretar
en base a la religión lo que podemos
saber interpretar en base a la ciencia
claro en ese época había otro ámbito que
era la filosofía
hay que distinguir
de tal manera que no es que hay una
noche obscura como se dice popularmente
entre los griegos y los hombres de
renacimiento no hay esa noche oscura
hemos mencionado a galileo hace un rato
el caso más famoso en ustedes todos
ustedes han visto en la universidad un
letrero que tiene un error además ahí no
pero bueno es otra historia sobre
galileo verdad un clero amarillo ignoro
un error pero bueno vayan y detecten el
error es del deber para mañana
en todo caso hemos hablado de galileo en
fin dijo por ejemplo el cardenal min
belarmino si estoy bien sobre esto miren
en la biblia no nos dice cómo van los
cielos
la biblia nos dice cómo se va al cielo
que es otra cosa diferente y sima no
podemos buscar en la biblia
las respuestas científicas el army no un
varón yo y otros dijeron lo mismo otros
personajes se equivocaron estoy de
acuerdo en eso
pero a dónde quiero ir llegando hay una
mentalidad
y acercarse a la realidad material desde
otra perspectiva
habrá gente que se opone estoy de
acuerdo pero les cuento una anécdota
todavía en 1916 aproximadamente y esto
lo cuente el doctor hugo alberto arcos
es historia de medición en el ecuador
había médicos en la central se oponían
al uso del microscopio
y decían que ha de estar viendo esos
bichitos en los título mundis y timón de
un aparato que se llama también
caleidoscopio
en nosotros de niños jugábamos para
jugar era muy lindos quedes perdiendo
visitó hace apenas 100 años
opositores a la ciencia lamentablemente
siempre había hay algo más
hemos mencionado el gran aporte
científico de los griegos y eso es
innegable tenemos que mencionar el gran
aporte científico de los árabes eso es
innegable pero hay un vínculo y un
transmisor entre la ciencia griega la
ciencia a árabe que significa escrita en
árabe que no siempre los que escriben en
árabe son árabes unos son de otras
etnias de otras religiones etc en todo
caso los árabes son grandes transmisores
de elementos científicos también hacen
progresar desde oriente a occidente
quién es el vínculo y el transmisor de
griegos árabes hacia europa la iglesia
la iglesia católica porque se conservan
los manuscritos de los pensadores
griegos romanos etcétera sobre todo
griegos porque los monjes los copiaron
todos los documentos los manuscritos que
nosotros tenemos en la actualidad vienen
del siglo 11 para acá
habla de manuscritos de carácter profano
no hablo de la biblia esa cosa que es
diferente ha nutrido de la biblia y
anteriores a jesucristo pero manuscritos
científicos piensen ustedes
euclides pitágoras etcétera los mismos
médicos en el siglo 11 para acá quien
mantuvo quien conservó esos manuscritos
la iglesia y en tradujo después en gran
parte no siempre sólo la iglesia pero
quien tradujo después la iglesia y
cuando llegan a españa o contamina
sicilia pero llegan a españa los sabios
árabes los sabios judíos sabios
cristianos quienes son los encargados de
llevar esta sabiduría esta ciencia a
estos principios de la ciencia hacia
occidente
son también iglesias ticos y nieva los
números que los árabes trajeron de la
india hacia occidente
obviamente mentor historia de los
números posicional es verdad pero llevan
a españa y en vic un sacerdote francés
servier toril ya que después era papá
lleva los números a occidente años más
tarde un par de siglos más tarde
fibonacci italia ya comienza a hacer sus
teoremas sus teorías en fin pero no es
el que lleva los números a europa dijo
más y ya recibe eso desde antes yo
tiendo hagan una pequeña un pequeño
ejercicio traten de hacer una simple y
elemental multiplicación en números
romanos y verán la dificultad el cambio
del número romano al número posicional
es fundamental para la ciencia
y hablando de números ya en esta época
estoy hablando de la edad media y hay
varios profesores universitarios que
dicen que sin las matemáticas no puede
haber ciencia
bien me queda mucho en el tintero verdad
mucho en el tintero pero quiero terminar
también con una lectura y voy a leer un
pequeño texto de alguien que no es
precisamente un coro chupa reaccionario
cavernario como el carlos fraile no es
un hombre más bien de avanzada uno de
los iconos del pensamiento posmoderno
norberto bobbio
norberto bobbio escribió
para mí la diferencia fundamental no se
da entre creyentes o no creyentes sino
entre pensantes y no pensantes o bien
entre quienes reflexionan sobre
los auténticos porqués y los
indiferentes que no reflexionan
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]